I believe in love I wouldn't be here if
I didn't believe in luck ask anybody who
knows me I'm one of the most romantic
people there is it's time for roses and
rose hey you guys were back I missed you
i'm lauren zima here to recap Becca
kufran season of The Bachelorette and
those words are so fabulous to say was
your mind blown just like Jake or Justin
or whatever his name is mind was blown
when Becca sent him home spoiler alert
not really you guys it's the dawn of a
new day the commencement of the new era
the start of a new chapter in our
journey one two three
Becca Cooper in season of The
Bachelorette has begun and the premiere
didn't blow my mind but I don't think it
was supposed to I think it was supposed
to be a palate cleanser just like this
delicious Rose a is for me it was
supposed to start us off strong and kind
and genuine be kind be smart be cool
Becca Cooper and that is and please
don't edit this out yeah so dressed like
Becca and those former bachelorettes
cleanse the mansion with sage we have
some sage for our set and yes I just
happen to have this in my desk I don't
know why but we can't actually light
anything here because you know fire
hazards so stage lighting stage sage
I'm gonna start with these couches cuz
this is where the men will be sitting
I'm gonna say we started off with Becca
sobbing and I guess that we have to what
I wish we didn't have to but anyway I
have decided not to acknowledge He Who
Shall Not Be Named I have also decided
not to really get into the guys intro
packages they were super fun but look
this premiere is about Becca so I am
only going to talk about moments that
involved Becca she deserves this
especially after he who must not be
named revealed his wedding date the week
of her premiere give it up anyway so
back it tells Chris Harrison that she
wants to find someone who is 110 percent
in it you think we need that extra 10%
yes because we found out what the
alleged hundred got us didn't we so
let's cut to the mansion to the hose
down driveway to the guys making
comments about how many more guys were
gonna see coming tonight even though
they know how many guys will see come in
tonight because it's about the same
number every episode of every season of
this show to the guys saying that
one-on-one time with Becca is clearly an
advantage yes these are all our stables
and we're finding comfort in them but
newness in the Bruce bazan liquid on the
shoes if so Becca meets genres long and
he has a terrible French accent she
means Joe I love Joe grocery store Joe
he stuttered he didn't know what to say
he was so cute you go Joe
Becca meets Leo and she tells him that
he has hair like her sisters he's not
gonna go far somebody reminds you of
your sister
[Music]
how are you Becca meets male model
Jordan and let's give Jordan some credit
because while on camera he says some
funny crap you know modeling is so much
more than being ridiculously
good-looking
we have chiseled abs and stunning
features he says that he spent six hours
hand selecting his outfit and then he's
gonna stand out because he's wearing
a gray suit just by me wearing gray I
will stand out and then Jordan goes
inside where another guy is wearing a
gray suit hello Dan Becca meets Garrett
Garrett comes in a minivan and I like
Garrett this was genuine this made me
smile this was sweet and most of all
Garrett knows the word rapport she's
witty and has quick rapport rapport
Blake arrives on an ox he is sweet and
he's wearing a salmon color jacket sorry
Jordan
by the way some weird names we have
wills we have Trent and then there's
Camille hey Becca come here Camille has
a rapport with social media his job
title is that he is a social media
participant well actually about 64 teams
and I can only think of the female named
Camille when I see Camille and if you
watch The Real Housewives on Bravo
especially that of Beverly Hills all
that I can think of is when Kyle
Richards infamously told Camille Grammer
quotes Camille
[Music]
[Applause]
so now we have one-on-one time and I
want to note during Becca's one-on-one
time with Blake she says things like I
feel like we can relate on so many
levels they get each other right away I
was in the same boat with my ex like
even though they don't know each other
she feels very connected to him pay
attention to this you guys because
there's a difference between saying that
someone has a great personality which
sounds like you're into them which means
you're sort of into them and saying that
you are on the same wavelength with
someone we heard from our previous
bachelorettes in the beginning of this
episode that you know reminder all of
our first impression roses went to the
guys that we are with now that's the
thing about this show you're not in the
real world you don't have real-life
situations so when you keep hearing
Becca say things like I'm gonna go with
my gut she has to go with her gut she
doesn't have anything else to go on
okay oh oh
JC is back there you guys needs just
informed me that my wine glass is being
blocked by the roses or an incredible
conflict of interest and what wins here
[Music]
the Rose a there is a guy here in the
house tonight that might not have the
purest intentions now we're going to
move on to the two what I'm calling ABCs
of the night absolutely bizarre
confrontations first some guy says that
a guy named chase isn't there for the
right reason because the first guy
texted with a girl who dated chase for a
little while and Chase is trying to
defend himself and part of his defense
is that he says him and his mom have
been watching the Bachelorette for a
while and like what and like why are you
guys bringing this to our girl Becca
she's trying to have a good night okay
don't bother her with this garbage
dumpster fire of a confrontation on her
first night Oh chase go home to your
mother it's awkward they're awkward
thank yous he awkwardly asked to hold
her hand can I hold your hands and then
plot twist it leads to ABC number two
because Becca wants to circle back with
Jake the guy who she knew from before
about why he's really there and that
leads us to the Lord
of the Christmas party is here for me or
what is he doing there
yes Jake remembers meeting back at a
Christmas party but Becca doesn't met
you many times before that and Jake's
defense of why he's there is
I only remember meeting you that one
time and Jake that's not a defense you
realize how absolutely insane you sound
right that would be a defense that you
don't remember meeting her Becca says
she doesn't think he's there for the
right reasons and ultimately sends him
home and Jake's mind is blown by a Jake
oh this is my favorite part I wanted you
to know that I've had a very
transformative year
guess what Jake so has backup this does
this does and she doesn't have time
anyway so we get some our one-on-one
time and then it's time for the first
impression rose and Becca gives it to
Garrett in the minivan Garrett is
someone that Becca says she's smitten
with again you guys remember that these
first impressions this woman's intuition
best black partner so we have our eye on
a few people and then the rose ceremony
starts in again back especially nice to
follow her gut and she send some people
home and I agree with a lot of her
choices like by Camille awesome chicken
man I chase but Jo oh no not Joe
I deal in protists for one thing I
haven't produced yet his long grocery so
Joe I like to show you guys he was
really sweet and I don't think he's got
a real chance I wish that you know how
sometimes I'm like singing competition
shows the judges get a vote to bring
somebody back even after the audience
has voted them off I'm in for that on
this show like let's let the audience
bring somebody back who they think would
be really good for Becca and in this
case Joe our drinking game tonight that
you shouldn't play because it's way too
dangerous is to drink every time we
talked about someone being there for the
right reasons already on night one
[Music]
that part wasn't easy that's always hard
to say goodbye overall everybody what I
would call a pretty tame premiere night
but again I think we needed that we
needed to settle in to the calm we
needed to see that He Who Shall Not Be
Named has been resorted to being a
cardboard cutout in the fabric of our
history of this show flat non
dimensional and disposable too much I
don't think so
but let's talk about the season promo
coming up this season
it's an unbelievable romantic adventure
that was where I got excited because I
do think we are still going to get the
dramatic show that we know and love even
though there is no job one thing I
haven't produced yet is life
so let's talk about things that we
learned from the season promo at the end
of the episode I'm falling in love with
you Blake falls in love with her
someone does to her what Ari did to her
who would do to Becca what Ari did to
Becca et blebs Becca a liar and
manipulator Lincoln s Lincoln might be a
really bad guy maybe it's linked it may
be linked it did to Becca what re did to
Becca you are a pathological liar chris
is gonna be the one who continues to
call people out just like you called out
chase Jordan looks like he gets a
two-on-one and that sounds pretty par
for the course on his personality if the
chicken stays and I go I just simply
embarrassed golden reveals he's a virgin
maybe the guys don't always believe him
there's no way whoa Blake looks great in
a trench coat and Lincoln seems to drink
a lot so don't drink every time Lincoln
drinks whose drinks a lot in the season
promo mm-hmm there's an ambulance visit
and someone's in a pool of blood
Becca falls in love with two guys we
knew that though because she told us
that last week during our et interview
with her check it out at easy online
calm shameless slug that's it those are
all my notes no mo notes I am so excited
for this season I really genuinely
enjoyed Becca and of course we are going
to be here every Monday night recapping
the Bachelorette on roses n rose a we
will also recap it live with roses and
roses a live every Tuesday morning with
a special veneration guests and
you guys need to check out our new
Facebook group it is all about the
Bachelorette and The Bachelor of course
when it returns you can head over and
check it out we will put a link in the
comments and we can talk every single
week about the episode as it happens
[Music]
thank you guys so much for being here
I'm so happy to be back with you I
missed you so much
bye by the way JC is sporting a man bun
JC comes over on the man bun much like
two of our suitors tonight oh yeah
JC dressed for the occasion this man
doesn't miss it premiere